muito obrigado
durante o lance
não foi um bom no um de três modos noite
com uma coleção de selos
a minha vida toda ela voltada para o
rápido em casa escutando a morar na
escola fazia a nós hoje não vai fazer a
aberto alguns que da apanha emergente
agente bacteriano
[Música]
fui para o hospital a fase mais marcante
foi o que aconteceu foi que eu estava
deitado na cama do hospital
então enquanto serra se espera dele
alguns amigos e ela falava
pensei alguma coisa está na hora de ver
foi quando eu percebi que eu estava
turno naquela momento estava provado dos
sons da natureza
a pergunta que levou a melhor e agora
depois fazer a europa muito mais escutar
a voz descoberta ano a cabeça do bom
claro que sou barros gestor daquela
escola mas teve de voltar para gaza
fundaram a comunidade negra do pará
tentando guardar dentro da minha
comunidade conversar com alguns
dirigentes mas eu estava surdo já não
havia química o que fiz foram por todos
os livros têm poder trabalhar o esporte
aos poucos a atender por perder o bafta
ramos foi de lei
eu posso falar pelos livros
a nova variedade de segunda classe por
terminar de voltar à escola
chegava na sala de aula o professor
chegou a falar que eu não percebi
absolutamente nada
durante três quatro cinco seis horas na
sala de aula final down e de um processo
de cadernos mude os clubes e para casa
para passar rapidamente por vez e do dem
estava completamente pesquisada
assim os desejos recrutava para casa
disse que apresentará o professor
fui um desses desde a integração do
derby
encontrei um grupo de surdos compra a
família também
além dos sinais da doença mostra que
houve essa expansão
eles são bons aproximando
perguntei onde jovens que estavam
ajudando a escola disse sem fazer essa
escolha por a 92 já não me lembro
verdade não faz muito tempo disse
estou na porta a classe tem 15 anos de
idade que gosta de dançar tem 111 deram
uma distância mas é ser o povo não
próprio fui keita o mesmo que vocês
estou sendo agora o brasil tem da cidade
porta passa em frente à unidade terceira
classe
quando pensei em tomar a decisão da
minha filha tem de fazer alguma 8
não vou cruzar os braços não estão
certos da vitória surgiu uma bolsa de
estudos foi para se fazer relações
internacionais história na universidade
pedagógica de toda a universidade toda
vez que eu não era própria para atender
pessoas com deficiência não foi para lá
que estão a perguntar
a falha sim mas é muito pouco à vontade
como o tio valdecir é como aprender
rápido em xangai mas eu falo ou escrevo
perfurou até ser o caminho a esposa de
[Música]
quebra do número de aulas
no final da aula vai ter tudo em aberto
e o que fazer durante o simpósio é
preciso dizer que todos em se á numa
área dessa história mas estarão três
gols pra onde
afinal os seus filhos para o trabalho e
fazer barulho
escrevi a 7 a favor dos réus é um
absurdo o que fizeram tomar a decisão
mais importante da minha vida e fazer
agora é bola para bola escreve artigos
em 2008
mandei cartas para trás e não estava
inscrito
o trabalho envolverá ações de pessoas
com deficiência
a versão não dispôs a 1 se você for ver
projectos relacionados com a mídia
esteve envolvido nesse trabalho gente
conhece uma jovem chamada pé o filho
dela senão o dom alano mousavi que tem
uma deficiência físico-motora o torcedor
que os pés têm pouca força mas longe o
barulhento
então ela ainda com dificuldade escreve
também com dificuldades
ela estava fazendo era da primeira com a
transportadora
então eu vejo que incomodou pode estar
na sala de aula onde o professor de
apontamentos ela tem problema nas mãos
então leva mais tempo para passar o
comportamento até que um novo pode
perder o papel de caderno
mas já falei as altas taxas não estão
muito escolhe ser difícil não por vez
tendo duas páginas que ela tinha de ter
o mesmo tempo que em relação aos clubes
não é global mas mesmo assim ela pensava
bastante bastante mesmo pedro no
computador da altura desenvolver uma
campanha nas redes você é esconder a
história dela conseguir
oferecemos um computador é defeito mas
ainda faltava a questão da mobilidade
ela rebola para transformar numa zona da
motorola e estudava na escola secundária
josina machel desenvolver uma outra
campanha até conseguiu se encontrar uma
pedra drogas há de ser o próximo a uma
sociedade
em dezembro do ano passado uma mensagem
do douro a 10
agora quero entrar para a universidade
uau os campeões disse
tão logo falei eu falei eu tenho quando
no poder
pedi para a minha esposa é perder nenhum
detalhe foi que você vê o abandono a
organização está a trabalhar
quero dar meus próprios para as
conversas de hoje 10
tomei uma decisão
vou criar uma associação para forçar o
líder pego da própria unidade de pessoas
com deficiência tem um diamante nas mãos
adams e nenhum dos dois é a mãe
precisamos de trabalhar ela vai ser dos
mais belos e valiosos que dizem vamos
criar mais libras por hora
faltaram à sessão devolver project saúde
para os advogados o rebanho leve que
falar a língua de sinais de medicamentos
comprados para o cérebro mais mobilidade
nas unidades sanitárias projeto no total
para joão e furos que não conseguem
entrar ainda do que é dito nas campanhas
normais por sua inclusão
vamos forçar mais dois filhos mais
velhos poucas de estudo capacitação da
pi no terremoto destruição prova
vamos criar um centro de formação
profissional para formar a letra sexta
rodada ordenar técnicos de frei ruiz
tagle inclusivo com professores que
estavam comunicar com as pessoas com
deficiência que comecei pelo tcu
etapa em são paulo que os usineiros é
possível nós a comunidade de pessoas com
deficiência não pega o time do bahia é
bom não
a gente não quer tudo ondas grandes na
estrutura luiz claudio taya do basco
jogar animar gerar outro próprio ps
alegamos comercializar desta forma
ajudam piloto pelo país a crescer
assim o time que precisa de dores
todos queremos ter para o
desenvolvimento deste país de áfrica e
tudo mundo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]